anyway here with reaction outnumbered
co-host Kaylee mcenany Fox News
contributor Ari Fleischer uh all right
let me start with the cocaine issue you
were both in the white house there's
certain areas of the White House and I
saw you both in the White House I had
the honor you know occasionally an
Administration will make a big mistake
and they'll allow me in the building
once or twice uh but I was there under
President Bush and president Trump and
uh correct me if I'm wrong Haley but
there are a lot of areas in that white
house I did not have free reign as a
guest in that house to just walk
anywhere I pleased without being watched
by a lot of people there were certain
rooms I was not able to walk into
without people with proper credentials
escorting me in that room so how did
that happen and wouldn't they be able to
quickly determine who brought that
cocaine in that white house
so that is definitely the case you could
narrow down based on the area so
oftentimes in the Trump Administration
we would send sit members of the press
who are meeting with the president and
the Press Room so if it's found in The
Press Room you'd think okay maybe the
Press who has access to this room it
wasn't found there you can roll out the
Press
um but then you have a series of
deductive reasoning at first we're told
it was in the library under the
residence all right tourists walk
through there then all of a sudden the
story changed now it's in the cubby
holes right when you walk into the West
executive entrance now staff brings
their guest right through there this the
staff guests are primarily who use that
but then all of a sudden Sean the story
changes once more why does it keep
changing now it's near The Situation
Room an area that only staff would have
access to so I would say at this point
it would have to be a staff member if
that reporting is true there are no
cameras inside the West Wing so that
makes it much more difficult but sit
down every staff member this was on a
Sunday uh very Lightfoot traffic sit
down every staff member who had access
to that area and try to figure it out
and I I assume that is exactly what the
Secret Service is doing right now well I
would say it's such a security breach
God forbid what if it had fentanyl in it
Ari Fleischer that I would imagine that
it would be a proper protocol to drug
test anybody and everybody that might
have had access to that room and Drug
Testing that is currently available
would allow people to give a hair sample
and we know pretty darn quickly whether
or not they've been using cocaine or not
yeah and the terms for working for the
president is you can be drug tested at
any time and so they have the right to
do that and no staff or can or should
refuse it if they refuse it I think you
know what we've got the only other
possibility of course is whether or not
it's a guest who was brought in by by
White House staff invited by the Biden
Administration officials that's not
uncommon especially on weekends for the
senior staff or staff with sufficient
clearance In The West Wing to escort
guests family members close friends to
give them that rare privileged West Wing
tour and somebody could have as they put
their phone in that cubby realized holy
cow look what I got in my pocket and
they shoved that in the cubby too so I
think that's all what the Secret Service
is looking for but I do want to tell
your audience something Kaylee just said
reiterate it there are no cameras I I
can't tell you how many times I've heard
people saying on TV there's cameras
everywhere this should be easy the
Secret Service just wants all their
agents to be vigilant on their toes they
don't have cameras in The West Wing okay
let me go to the question all of a
sudden the Atlantic uh
uh all these Publications maureened out
axios about Biden's temper uh AOC is
excoriated by prominent Democrats
excoriated all over social media for
supporting Joe Biden why do I believe
the beginning of the possible takedown
of Biden has begun and it's desired by
both the medium mob Kaylee mcinany and
also by the Democratic party apparatchik
if you will itself they want him out and
they're now looking to push him out I
will give you an example in New York it
was not Republicans that that got Andrew
Cuomo out of office it was the
Democratic party that made that happen I
would argue the people that are pushing
Joe Biden not to run are Democrats and
is now getting louder by the day you
agree disagree
I completely agree you have an Atlantic
piece that's a left-wing publication
saying step aside Joe Biden at the exact
same time you get The Mooring down piece
in the New York Times talking about his
grandchild just days after you get a
piece from Katie Rogers who's a reporter
at the New York Times excoriating Joe
Biden and then you just said it yourself
in axio's piece too and axios has in my
view been carrying a lot of the talking
points from the Biden Administration you
can pretty clearly see that and then all
of a sudden boom axios hits him it's as
if some Central memo went out to the
Press I do not believe it's just
one-offs I think their end goal they
realize look Donald Trump could beat Joe
Biden if he's the nominee it's the last
thing the Press wants so they're putting
the heat under Joe Biden but it might be
best laid plans because outside of Joe
Biden saying look the Heat's too hot I'm
stepping aside or maybe there's a pile
of money over in China he wants to take
advantage of in the private sector life
outside of something like that I don't
see a path to the nomination for anyone
else again this incumbent going after
and they gave specific details in axios
his vicious temporary and Maureen Dowd
going after the seventh grandchild
something I brought up many times the
fact that he's gotten a pass up to this
point is you know just more evidence of
how abusably corrupt and biased media is
but Maureen Dow just laid it out as well
as anybody never thought those words
would come out of my mouth but it took
this long that tells me how bad they
want him gone
a couple things one you know I don't
read Maureen dad from the New York Times
but I read that well neither do I
usually I did read that column and she
is the snide conscience of the
democratic party and that was a moral
gut punch to Joe Biden to the Democrats
that the man has done something immoral
and that really hurts when it comes from
your own base I think the you said they
all got the memo at the same time I
think the memo that they're all seeing
is seeing on a regular basis is he's
running dead even with Donald Trump or
barely ahead and that scares the hell
out of the Democrats their calculation
is they've got to avoid Trump at all
costs and they think a new generation a
different Democrat would run stronger
against Donald Trump so they're scared
that Joe Biden can't put Donald Trump
away Donald Trump under indictment and
they can't even put him away Biden can't
so I think that is the realization that
shaking these Democrats that are now
putting this pressure on Joe Biden and I
would not be surprised if Biden pulls
the LBJ 68 and does decide at some point
later this fall early in the winter that
he is not going to run for reelection I
I would not be surprised either Exit
question for both of you Ari because you
went there first I'll ask you uh will
Joe Biden be the nominee for the
Democrats in November of 2024. yeah I
really think it's a 50 50 proposition
and I think it's going to be largely
determined by his health and by the
polls and if his health and the polls is
bad it won't be Biden and if any health
issues emerge for Joe Biden of any
serious nature it won't be Joe Biden
what do you think Kelly
I think he's the nominee without a doubt
I think it's the best wishes of the
press that he steps aside this man
you're looking at right there he's
stubborn he's a stubborn old man just go
read his quotes to 23 year old staffers
that include many f-bombs and expletives
he's not going anywhere but you could
try your best
let me tell you how precarious it is and
I'll I'll take the last word if you will
grant me that Liberty I think he's one
maybe two of the maximum Falls away from
being pushed out he is one or two
massive gaffs away I mean really bad gas
not the garden variety daily gaffe away
from from a real movement to push him
out of the way but we'll see time will
tell thank you both hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else